bonjour si méline jean baptiste vous
êtes parole du comité de soutien au
professeur de musique danse et théâtre
diplômé de la martinique le monde
culturel de notre île qui est en
ébullition l'artiste hervé de luze qui
fonce avec sa voiture dans l'atrium et
puis votre comité qui fait irruption en
plénière à l'assemblée de martinique la
semaine dernière madame jean mathis mme
les artistes sont sous tension dans
notre île oui
les artistes sont sous tension chez nous
d'ailleurs j'en profite comme vous
parlez de monsieur hervé de luge pour le
comité en tout cas souhaite s'adresser à
sa famille est adressée sous son soutien
à sa famille est également souhaite
s'adresser au peuple martiniquais qui
comprennent la démarche de cet artiste
qui
qui donne accès de colère de
l'exaspération très certainement a agi
de la sorte nous nous taisions la raison
de cette exaspération
les raisons je ne les connais pas
véritablement je ne pourrais pas vous
donner les raisons qui ont poussé hervé
de luge à aller vers à faire ce geste
toutefois le geste d'hervé est le geste
de tous les artistes martiniquais
c'est à dire que ça aurait pu être
n'importe lequel d'entre nous nous nous
sommes actuellement dans une précarité
dans notre secteur professionnel qui est
alarmant et nous nous soutenons ce hervé
hier encore nous étions donc voilà
l'atrium et devant le poste pauliste
nationale nous avons joué de la musique
pour lui voulu faire comprendre qu'ils
savent que nous la lépi et n'est que
tout ne savent que nou la épi
alors vous manifester votre soutien à
hervé de luge mais vous adresser
également la population à travers cette
mobilisation d'hier soir à travers votre
intervention à l'assemblée de martinique
pour dire que les artistes se forment de
plus en plus mais que malheureusement il
n'y a pas de politique culturelle
adaptée à cette vos exigences
d'aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait alors jeudi dernier nous
sommes rendus à la première plénière de
l'année à la ctm pour pouvoir dire trois
choses à à la ctm aux élus en tout cas
la première est de mettre en place le
schéma départemental des enseignements
artistiques et de mettre en place le
plan de formation le plan régional de la
formation professionnelle en matière
artistique
troisième chose c'était c'est d'engager
de façon imminente
nos deux collègues vaïty simone et
nathalie yards à nu qui sont toutes les
deux titulaires du concours de la
fonction publique territoriale grade à
et gratte b qui peuvent justement
permettre aux collectivités de mettre en
place ce schéma départemental et ce plan
est la troisième chose que nous
souhaitions que nous souhaitons toujours
cdc de pouvant intégrer ce plan
d'établissement de
de structuration vous avez entendu la
réponse de marie-hélène et on te
rappelles et la conseillère exécutive en
charge des affaires culturelles dans
notre île
elle reconnaît qu'il y a des déficits
mais elle dit surtout qu'il n'ya pas
d'argent il n'y a pas de structures
capables d'absorber d'absorber par
exemple ces deux personnes simone veil
ti et nathalie ardanuy vous l'entendez
vous voulez faire avec vous vouliez tout
vous rejeté tout en bloc
alors je vais d'abord commencé par dire
quelque chose
la réussite d'un projet ne dépend pas de
son financement mais de son
investissement de l'est facilement qu'on
y porte de la notion de volonté
politique vous août et de cette volonté
politique de la part de nos élus
j'en doute oui et non c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui j'ai peut-être l'impression
en train de le collectif a peut-être
l'impression que qu'il ya une espèce de
dualité entre entre projet c'est à dire
que nous avons été reçus suite à notre
intervention à la plénière jeudi dernier
nous avons été reçus par madame les
hautains et madame qui s'anime annuel
pour savoir déjà ça fait déjà à peu près
deux ans approximativement que nous
sommes en relation avec madame léotin
vaïty a été reçu par madame les auteurs
a eu des rendez vous il ya une réelle
interaction sur la notion de politique
culturelle également intégration et
l'urgence du risque de la perte de leur
concours à l ena taljaard à nu
c'est bien pour cela que d'ailleurs nous
sommes venus à cette plénière parce que
ça fait déjà un très long temps que leur
faut le dire aux élus qu'il fallait
faire très vite qu'il faut faire très
vite
et puis de surtout respecter les lois
c'est à dire que le schéma départemental
est issu de la loi du 13 août 2004 la
loi du 13 août 2004 est clair je vais
vous lire un passage si vous le
permettez la loi de décentralisation du
13 août 2004 clarifie les
responsabilités des différentes
collectivités locales en matière
d'enseignement artistique musique danse
théâtre la cité elle sait exactement son
rôle donc de déléguer aux municipalités
et de mettre en place des pressions que
le septième aux dépens des textes de loi
je ne sais pas si la city elle ne
connaît pas les textes parmi toutefois
si c'est le cas nous sommes là pour le
rappeler
oui parce que aujourd'hui est ce
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'impression que ce
coup de force à l'assemblée de
martinique jeudi dernier et près ce qui
s'est passé avec hervé de luge est ce
que cela va créer un électrochoc au
niveau des élus et même de la population
parce ce que vous voulez voulait surtout
dire que un peuple comme le nôtre la
martinique ne peut pas vivre sans ces
artistes pop n'est pas sensé artistes en
fait ne peut pas vivre non plus samson
intellectualisation sur son patrimoine
son historicité tout simplement nous
avons suit d'ailleurs à 7
à cette intervention était reçu par le
maire du prêcheur qui nous a soutenus
nous a exprimé son soutien donc moi je
pense quand même que les élus les
députés les sénateurs toutes ces
personnes qui sont à la charge de la
politique
en martinique sont quand même conscients
des menaces qu'ils revendiquent la
culture dans toute l'europe
maniaque oui la culture est toujours
mise en avant et puis on a l'impression
que vous enfin vous l'avez exprimé très
clairement l'impression que on en parle
souvent pendant la campagne et puis
après une fois qu'on est au pouvoir ça
disparaît oui ce manque de considération
un manque de considération peut-être
est-ce un oubli je ne sais pas
véritablement ce qui se passe dès lors
où on est en campagne électorale et
conques ont finalement séduit la
population avec des projets d'envergure
avec des projets pour l'avancement du
pays
et puis qu une fois que ces personnes
sont au pouvoir
ben elle s'excuse de manque de moyens
financiers et s'excuse de manque de
temps alors qu'il faudrait simplement
avoir la volonté de le faire aimer 6 ea
l'a très bien montré il a ouvert le
chemin pour nous et peut-être même que
monsieur de luge et ce qu'il a voulu
faire
en ouvrant les portes de l'atrium
sylvain jean baptiste lorsqu'on parle
d'artistes n'y a pas que celui qui joue
du piano de la guitare il y à toute une
variété de métiers autour du corps
artistique
est-ce que j'ai l'impression que la
population le sait en a conscience
je pense qu'il ya effectivement une
information peut être erronée ou mal
connus du secteur artistique aujourd'hui
j'entends beaucoup de personnes parler
de conservatoire qu'il faut qu'ils le
conservatoire commenté nic pourtant
conservatoire n'est autre qu'une école
de musique régionale est pas encore là
certains critères un peu plus et plus
élevé plus élevés non parce qu'en fait
c'est de l'enseignement initial et c'est
ce qu'ont eu de mandant c'est à dire
qu'elle a aujourd'hui nous avons des
élus qui souhaitent mettre en place une
structure supérieure d'arts mais c'est
comme si en martinique nous mettions
universités en marche et nous oublions
de mettre une école maternelle une école
primaire et un lycée on peut pas me
demander à des enfants de 3 ans de
rentrer dans une université vous
comprenez ce que je vais dire ah oui je
comprends parfaitement
il nous faut juste convaincre des élus
est peut-être la population pour qu'elle
puisse également faire pression sur ces
élus soient plus que vous voulez faire
pression et puis voyez
jeudi dernier nous étions à la peinière
de la ctm et quatre jours après on est
nanti ce qui crie son désarroi piqueries
sur ces problématiques dans le secteur
artistique
vous dites que l'art en martinique
l'expression artistique rythme tous nos
événements des rythmes de notre
quotidien nous avons besoin de cela
c'est spontané il mais il faut il faut
qu'on soit formé pour cela c'est
spontané parce que culturellement fin
nous avons une culture qui qui fait que
à chaque combat que nous avons eu à
faire pour nos droits nous avons utilisé
justement notre culture notre notre nom
pour pouvoir faire entendre notre voix
notamment
oui je pense d'ailleurs à l'esclave room
qui a été acquis grâce à lui en fait
nous avons pu être
nous avons pu être affranchi de l'
esclavage parce qu'il est interdit de
jouer et que l'aliment ticket à l'époque
se sont mobilisés à plus tard que le 14
février 1974 nous avions deux ouvriers
décédés sur sur un plateau à chalvet et
là encore la musique était ici était
présente hier 14 février symboliquement
encore nous étions dans les rues avec la
musique
toutefois pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
avoir deux structures professionnelles
dans le monde artistique nous envions
nono nos voisins de cuba nous voisins du
brésil et même notre excusez moi
l'expression notre cher papa de la
france et pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
nous enfants nous émanciper vous
demandez aux martiniquais en
martiniquaise qui nous écoutent
d'envoyer leurs enfants dans toutes les
écoles de musique de peinture de
sculpture mais c'est déjà ce qu'ils font
c'est très paradoxal
nous vivons avec l'art tous les jours le
sermac ir remplie d'élèves
je voulais même inscrire les cours
étaient déjà complets vous comprenez
donc l'art c'est quelque chose qui est
primordial c'est normal ça reflète notre
identité ça contribue au rayonnement de
notre pays ça contribue au rayonnement
de notre pays
pourquoi toujours devons nous aller vers
l'extérieur pour prendre des autres
alors que on a besoin d'apprendre de
nous mêmes et que beaucoup de personnes
souhaitent avoir de nous mêmes
merci 6 mai linh jean baptiste d'avoir
été avec nous rappelle que vous n'êtes
pas parole du comité de soutien au
professeur de musique danse et théâtre
diplômé de la martinique et vous l'avez
dit la culture c'est un marqueur de
notre société il faut donc l'appuyer va
soutenir merci bonne journée
j'aimerais rajouter que sans la culture
sans sa culture la martinique personnes
historicité sa mémoire son héritage et
par conséquent son identité mais surtout
son devenir
merci aujourd'hui au revoir